bonsoir nous sommes le 18 novembre et
dans l'actualité aujourd'hui les avocats
qui se mobilisent à travers la France la
justice bloquée en raison d'une grève
sans précédent pour dénoncer les projets
de réforme de la profession la Semaine
de prévention des accidents domestiques
se poursuit att trrape Janine Marie mer
adjoin de la commune en plateau pour en
parler alors que l'Institut national de
prévention et d'éducation pour la santé
recense 20000 décès par an liés à ce
type d'accident il prépare un gala dans
quelques jours les magiciens du cœur
interviennent tout au long de l'année
auprès des enfants malades dans les
hôpitaux il seront en plateau tout à
l'heure avec la marine de l'association
c'est l'un des derniers concurrents
encore en course dans cette catégorie
monoco des 18 m 28 Tangui de la Motte
est arrivé tout proche de la Guadeloupe
il va boucler dans la nuit sa première
course du Rome avec ce bateau le skipper
versaillais euh en mer depuis le 2
novembre et son départ de saint-malot a
connu une dernière nuit difficile sa
plus grande voile a été déchirée
rappelons qu'il concourrait une fois de
plus afin de récolter des fonds pour
initiative cœur avec le soutien de
messena Chirurgie Cardiaque les fonds
récoltés qui servent à l'opération
d'enfant
malade justice et comme prévu les
avocats qui étaient en grève aujourd'hui
un mouvement rare pour cette profession
ils ont déjà exprimé leur mécontentement
après la réforme envisagée par Emmanuel
Macron mais cette fois-ci c'est bien
l'ensemble des audiences qui ont été qui
a été reporté notamment à Versailles
Mélanie poket Anthony res et William
l ils appellent à la mobilisation
générale en ligne de miè des avocats les
lois Macron et tobira ces lois
envisagent entre autres la création d'un
statut d'avocat d'entreprise il est
question d'intégrer des juristes
d'entreprise qui non n'ayant pas la même
notion du secret professionnel risque
involontairement ou volontairement
d'étaler n'importe comment et de rendre
disponibles des secrets qui sont
professionnels est-ce que vous imaginez
un secret médical qui serait répandu de
façon incontrôlable je n'imagine pas je
n'imagine pas non plus pour les avocats
comme il est question de l'introduction
des capitaux qu'on risque d'avoir des
sociétés d'avocats qui se baseraient
exclusivement sur la rentabilité et pour
lesquelles la seule notion dans un
dossier serait de voir si le dossier est
rentable je n'imagine pas qu'on puisse
traiter une accidente un accident une
réparation corporelle en un quart
d'heure dans une tour de la défense je
n'imagine pas non plus qu'on puisse
divorcer de cette façon-là nous avons
prêté cement d'humanité les juristes
d'entreprise pourraient ainsi devenir
avocat après 5 ans d'expérience minimum
la mobilisation est prévue jusqu'à la
fin de la semaine les avocats doivent
manifester vendredi la mobilisation est
mal connue du grand public la profession
ayant l'image de privilégié ce qui n'est
pas forcément le cas on est dans une
situation vraiment très très complexe on
a des jeunes confrères qui forcément
entament leur activité
en en acceptant d'intervenir au titre de
l'aide juridictionnelle et qui
aujourd'hui ne s'en sortent plus et qui
se retrouvent dans une situation
d'exprème précarité on entend trop
souvent dire que les avocats
représentent une profession
particulièrement
privilégiés avec des avocats qui
auraient des revenus confortables
aujourd'hui au nom des jeunes confrères
je dois vous dire que c'est totalement
une hérésie de pouvoir se permettre de
dire ça le Barreau de Versailles compte
avocats pas de neige encore en vue mais
les températures ont bien baissé les
agents du Conseil général des evvelines
sont eux depuis lundi en astreinte dans
le cadre du Plan hiver les engins de
dénaigement sont prêts à rentrer en
action les stocks de sell sont aussi
plein détail Catherine zulato et Lim
moine rappelez-vous hiver 2010 des
centaines d'automobilistes bloqués un
enfer que les collectivités n'ont pas
vraiment envie de revivre le Conseil
général a mise en place son plan hiver
depuis ce lundi centre d'exploitation de
saint-ciier l'école un des neuf sites
gérés par le Département les camions
équipés de salleuse sont déjà
positionnés en tout on a 130 agents qui
sont mobilisés et en permanence sur ces
130 agents on en a une quarantaine qui
sont placés sous astreinte donc il y a
des systèmes de roulement pour les
astreintes qui font que en permanence on
a une quarantaine d'agents disponible
pour intervenir une veille météo est
assurée des renseignements fournis
toutes les heures et qui permettent le
déclenchement des intervention le
Conseil général a en charge 1400 km de
route départementale bien vient pas de
la même manière sur toutes les routes on
a ce qu'on appelle un niveau de priorité
un niveau de classement qui est
prédéfini on a des routes de niveau N1
qui correspondent aux itinéraires
principaux dans les Yvelines donc ça ça
représente à peu près 550 km ensuite on
a les routes un petit peu moins
importantes c'est les N2 et les routes
vraiment rurales les routes secondaires
départementales c'est le niveau N3 les
axes classés prioritaires doivent être
dégagés le plus rapidement dans les 4 He
au maximum le Conseil général intervient
donc sur les routes départementales les
voies communales sont de la
responsabilité des villes et l'état
gèent de son côté les Nationales des
moyens aujourd'hui coordonnés pour être
le plus efficace possible mais pour les
agents d'astreinte la crainte principale
la neige qui tombe en fin de journée le
conseil est toujours le même surtout ne
prenez pas votre voiture s'il se met à
neiger au moment le soir à l'heure de
rentrer chez vous faites en sorte de
pouvoir prendre les transports en commun
ou si possible de rentrer à pied mais
évitez à tout prix de prendre votre
voiture dans vraiment s'il y a un gros
phénomène n jeu à la limite il vaut
mieux rester à son
bureau rester un petit peu plus tard le
département dispose de 25 sleuse et d'un
stock de 3800 tonnes de sel un budget
d'achat conséquent de 600000 € l'an
passé faute de neige seulement 150
tonnes ont été consommé le sel restant
pourra être réutilisé cette année le
dispositif hiver prend fin au 15 mars
mais pour l'heure pas de flocon en vue
les températures restent douces pour la
saison nous en parlions déjà hier dans
notre précédente édition la Semaine de
la prévention des accidents domestiques
s'est ouvert à trappe les risques sont
nombreux les risques de chute électrique
incendie intoxication alimentair les
conséquences parfois dramatiques
l'Institut national de prévention et
d'éducation pour la santé l'INPS parle
de 20000 décès par an bonsoir Jeanine
Marie vous êtes maère adjointe à trappe
une dizaine de rendez-vous qui sont
proposés dans votre commune à travers
toute la commune plusieurs lieux
pourquoi vous saisir de ce problème
pourquoi intervenir avec l'aide de la
maison des parents je précise alors
l'aide de la maison des parents est
porteur de nombreux projets dans
celui-là que nous essayons de maintenir
de façon régulière de façon à à ce que
la sensibilisation que nous faisons
auprès des familles soit bien
persistante dans leur dans leur esprit
nous avons euh au niveau de la petite
enfant des repérages d'enfants qui si
ont des des des problèmes lié aux
incidents aux accidents domestiques qui
sont euh qui sont quand même assez
importants parfois donc on se rend bien
compte que il faut revenir sans cesse
sur cette sensibilisation et c'est
pareil pour les personnes âgées
puisqu'on parle des jeunes enfants ça
Meux toujours mais quand on regarde les
chiffres sur les personnes âgées ce sont
surtout les personnes âgées qui sont
très atteintes par par les accidents
domestique plus de 65 % des accidents de
personne de plus de 75 ans c'est dû à
une chute par exemple donc vous
sensibilisez sont des conses qui sontés
le foyer de personnes âgées le foyer
pourcassa participe à cette
manifestation hein de façon active
d'ailleursin et c'est bien mais il
faudrait élargir au-delà de ce foyer là
parce que sur la ville nouvelle sur la
ville de trappe compris sur la ville
nouvelle d'ailleurs aussi le le problème
des personnes âgées est en train de
monter de façon
importante et je suis pas sûr qu'on
anticipe toujours tout ce qu'il faut
donc nous essayons petit à petit de de
toucher le plus possible de personnes
âgées pour les sensibiliser à ces
problèmes là parce que il y a des chutes
mais il y a aussi beaucoup de blessés on
parle des des morts il y a 2700000
blessés tous les ans donc c'est vraiment
un problème que les pouvoir public
municipalité doit prendre doit prendre
en compte aujourhu motiv votre problème
de de solidarité citoyenne envers les
aînés tout au moins même s'il faut pas
uniquement parler des décès mais aussi
des accidents je vais quand même
rappeler que les accidents de la vie
courante c'est la troisème cause de
mortalité en France c'est même juste
derrière les cancers alors l'idée c'est
aussi de proposer peut-être quelque
chose d'interactif là je pense pour les
pour les plus jeunes il y aura du mardi
au jeudi à la salle Jean-Baptiste
Clément une Maison des Géants maison
tourisque aussi enfin com et la maison
des géant elle est très connue mais il y
a aussi la maison tour risque il y a
aussi le monsieur qui sait tout hein qui
sait tout sauf ce qu'il ne sait pas
justement sur le thème des accidents
domestiques il y a aussi des pièces de
théâtre interactives il y a aussi les
pompiers qui interviennent alors plus
pour les parents comment éteindre
l'incendie d' une friteuse qui prend qui
prend feu ça on sait pas toujours on na
pas forcément le bon réflexe et euh et
d'autres thèmes comme ça il y a aussi la
société valofice qui a un appartement
témoin avec tous les risques de de
l'appartement à deviner pour ceux qui
passe dans l'appartement on fait on fait
ce que l'on peut on essaie de faire plus
à chaque fois on voit des images de
cette maison déjà enfin on a vu y a
quelques il y a quelques instants pour
ceux qui ne connaissent pas en fait on
est mis en situation dans la peau d'un
enfant cette fois-ci vous l'avez utilisé
c'est proportionnel à la taille de la
personne donc évidemment les portes de
placard es sont immensément hautes les
marches sont immensément hautes aussi
parce que bah c'est proportionnel à la
taille donc les parents se rendent pas
toujours compte quels sont les les
retours justement que vous avez pour
l'instant des différents
ateliers les retours que l'on a eu parce
que c'est pas la première fois que nous
faisons ça les retours que l'on a eu
c'est la prise de conscience de la
dimension de l'enfant par rapport à la
réalité de de son environnement et là il
se r plus là attends mais moi c'est oui
bah oui oui oui oui oui oui tu es toute
petite et tu regardes en haut et et
voilà voilà il y a prise de concience
prise de conscience une prise de
conscience et compris pour les jeunes
dos he qui gardent souvent les les
enfants de soir et qui se rendent pas
compte des difficultés de leurs petit
frères ou petite sœur et là quand ils
sont là ils se disent oui il y a un truc
là que j'ai pas compris voilà la prise
de conscience est important
sensibilisation tout au long de la
semaine le programme complet retrouvez
bien sûr sur votre site internet vous
avez des partenaires aussi à cette
occasion partenaires nombreux vous avez
mentionné quelquesuns peut-être parler
des des assurances aussi a la Maï qui
participe parce que même si on prévoit
tout aussi bien la Maïf qui est très
présente auprès de nous et ça c'est
important je les remercie qui ont
participé à ces ateliers vous disiez
c'est pas la première année ce sera REC
vous allez renouvel encore cette
opération c'est quelque chose qui fait
qui estancré attrape c'est quelque chose
qu'on essaie de maintenir voilà très
bien merci j Marie d'êtreevenenu nous en
parler de ces ateliers de de prévention
semaine de prévention sur ses accidents
domestiques att trrape nous poursuivons
ce journal et lundi à la grande écurie
du château de Versailles le concept de
l'qui coaching qui a été présenté à
différentes entreprises des managers des
dirigeants encore des commerciaux qui
ont pu s'essayer à cette activité pour
laquelle le cheval devient révélateur de
leur trait de caractère vous allez le
voir avec yoline torrz développer ses
talents de leader de communicquant et
son esprit d'équipe c'est possible grâce
à l'equy coaching par la relation avec
le cheval les participants peuvent
notamment travailler la gestion du
stress ou la confiance en soi allez-y
vous pouvez ramener la main voilà soyez
détendu parce qu'elle sent que vous êtes
un peu inquiet le cheval il met moins
d'une seconde pour savoir qui vous êtes
profondément et il doit pour des raisons
de sécurité propre vous estimer de façon
précise et efficace s'il se trompe sur
vous il se met en danger lui a pas
encore l'idée qu' il est domestiqué qu'
risque plus rien il est encore à l'état
de nature dans son comportement et c'est
de ça qu'on va se servir pour pouvoir
travailler avec les gens lors de cette
journée porte ouverte lundi et la grande
écurie du château de Versailles managers
dirigeants et commerciaux de diverses
entreprises sont venus s'essayer pour la
première fois cette expérience en 3
minutes en utilisant le cheval comme
miroir des émotions l'instructeur a su
dresser quelques traits de caractère de
Patrick vous avez montré aussi des
vraies capacités d'adaptation je pense
que ça quand vous êtes dans un groupe
vous savez voilà vous adaptez à
l'environnement assez facilement vous
noyer et mettre les gens à l'aise autour
de vous dans ce coaching très tourné
vers la vie d'entreprise les
participants y voi de véritables atouts
pour la gestion de leurs équipes il y a
choses qui sont sur le enfin qui est
basé sur la communication non verbale ou
corporelle qu'onexlooite pas
suffisamment et là effectivement
peut-être qu'avec un tiers qui ne parle
pas précisément mais qui ressent
peut-être être une une expérience
intéressante je pense qu'au niveau de la
société ça peut être très intéressant de
faire une journée de découverte aussi
bien pour nos salariés que pour
nous-même de se remettre en question de
se découvrir et en même temps avec le
côté ludique du cheval peut-être
découvrir des loisirs voilà pour les
salariés qui veulent ensuite pratiquer
l'équitation et
l'éthologie je reçois à présent deux
invités Denis vaovard bonsoir vous êtes
le président de l'association magicien
du cœur et face à vous la marine de
cette association Genel Rousel bienvenue
également vous êtes auteur compositeur
chanteuse beaucoup de sujets pour
évoquer avec vous vous ne manquez pas
d'actualité premier sujet c'est ce gala
le 2 novembre au Centre municipal des
loisirs à Montfort lamoris à 20h30 il y
aura une dizaine d'artistes sur scène
des magiciens mais vous également vous
serez présenté à leur côté pour une
petite représentation comment ça va se
dérouler ce ce gala voors annuellement
on fait un gala pour financer notre
association pour permettre à notre
association de de tourner de de payer
ses frais
et là vous promettez mystère humour
émotion ah ouais il y aura mystère
humour ouou vendu comm comme ça il y
aura il y aura tout ça sur sur scène et
c'est pour pour nous aussi c'est
l'occasion de se produire sur scène
puisque tout au long de l'année les
magiciens qui vont dans les hôpitaux
font du chambre à chambre donc une
discipline qu'on appelle plutôt le
closeup le closeup c'est la magie de
près parce que c'est le but de cette
association on y vient donc tout de
suite le but c'est de d'aller voir ses
enfants malades de leur offrir un
échappatoir quelques temps ils oublient
la maladie oui c'est ce qu'on appelle en
magie un détournement d'attention donc
quand on va quand on va dans les
chambres on fait de la magie et là on
est dans un autre monde et en général on
oublie tout et on passe des moments
agréables avec les enfants et à faire et
des fois avec les parents qui sont qui
sont aussi dans les chambres donc c'est
le moment aussi de de s'amuser aussi
avec les parents de les prendre comme
complice et de faire un petit un petit
moment magique avec toute la famille
donc ce GSL servira à financer ses
activités c'est 10 € par adulte 5 € pour
les moins de 12 ans les recettes
uniquement pour l'association des des
magiciens du cœur vous allez nous
expliquer comment a né un petit peu
cette cette initiative mais peut-être la
marine tout d'abord comment vous êtes
arrivé à travailler avec l'association
comment vous les avez rencontré alors
c'est c'est assez récent mais c'est une
belle rencontre je crois qu'on s'est
découvert une affinité commune pour pour
la magie euh effectivement moi l'année
dernière j'avais fait un spectacle en
partenariat avec la mairie de Montfort
laamoris autour de de de Merlin donc et
de de l'univers de sa magie et donc j'ai
été mise en contact avec les magiciens
du cœur avec Denis et Alain conogito et
euh et c'est vrai que j'ai été très
honorée d'être sollicité pour euh pour
être la marine de cette de cette belle
initiative parce que je trouve que c'est
euh c'est c'est c'est assez
extraordinaire d'avoir déjà cette cette
longévité parce que c'est une
association qui existe depuis depuis
très longtemps que les magiciens sont
tous bénévoles et je tiens à à le
préciser parce que c'est vrai que c'est
c'est important et ils se rendre donc
plusieurs fois par semaine euh dans les
hôpitaux j'ai j'ai moi-même eu la chance
d'accompagner Denis euh un jour à
l'hôpital de Versailles et effectivement
comme il le disait très justement tout à
l'heure c'est c'est c'est c'est très
chouette de voir à quel point des des
gens qui sont passionnés et généreux
comme ils le sont apportent du réconfort
à des enfants de de tous les âges et
aussi aux parents qui accompagnent les
enfants et pour qui la situation est est
aussi difficile et de voir cette cette
magie dans briller dans les yeux de de
de tous ceux qu'il visitent 220
déplacements 2500 enfants rencontrés
chaque année à peu près on a fait quand
on a fait ce calcul on en revenait pas
alors comment est née cette initiative
cette volonté de faire rentrer la magie
à l'hôpital il y a une quinzaine
d'années notre président d'honneur à
incognito a a eu une initiative pour un
enfant qui était malade donc il a réuni
des magiciens pour récolter des fonds
pour aider cet enfant malade et bah
après
naturellement ça s'est prolongé donc il
y a une association qui s'est qui s'est
créé et les les magiciens qui avaient
participé au
au début de l'association ont prolongé
leur leur engagement en allant
régulièrement dans les hôpitaux
aujourd'hui nous sommes une vingtaine de
une vingtaine de magiciens donc ce qui
explique les 220 déplacements par an et
les c'est difficile de rentrer dans les
hôpitaux on imagine que c'est un milieu
plutôt fermé que le corps médical n pas
forcément
toujours quand on rentre dans les
hôpitaux on signe une convention avec
les avec la direction de de l'hôpital et
on s'engage à y aller
régulièrement et c'est vrai qu'on
rencontre les enfants on rencontre les
familles mais aussi il y a des
rencontres avec les le le personnel
soignant parce que quand on va à
l'hôpital on y va régulièrement donc on
connaît les on connaît les infirmières
on connaît les médecins et là aussi il y
a au bout d'un moment il y a une
complicité qui qui sopère j'ai une une
anecdote à un hôpital j'allais au début
donc j'étais pas très connu j'allais
dans une chambre je faisais de la magie
une infirmière rentrait
elle elle allait faire soins aujourd'hui
dans ce même hôpital je fais de la magie
l'infirmière rentre ah bah Denis je
repasserai tout à l'heure donc elle me
laisse et c'est vrai parti du personnel
de l'hôpital aussi un peu ouis on ma
déjà dit tu fais partie de l'équipe donc
c'est vrai que c'est c'est quand même
une belle gratification de de de sentir
qu'on est intégré et que bah qu'il y a
des choses vraiment sympathiques qui se
passent avec aussi bien le le
personnellement soignant que les que les
malades et pour permettre tout ça il y a
ce gars là qui permettra de récolter
donc des fond les magiciens sur scène
magiciens bénévoolle vous l'avez bien
rappelé et puis vous également vous
serez sur scène puisque vous êtes
chanteuse auteur compositeur on va
regarder un extrait de d'un de vos clips
justement Merlin on reste dans le
domaine de la magie
exactement Merin dans sa tour d'
invisible attend que sa belle
délire j'ai vous fait ma mise de moi
pauvre a r
[Musique]
conduit c'est vrai je vous ai tout
appris le moindre secret de
[Musique]
magie et je vous implore
aujourd'hui de ma prison douce et
concentrée
nous parlons ce soir du travail des
magiciens du cœur et aussi de
l'implication de de la marine que l'on
vient d'entendre sur ce titre on fait
juste une petite parenthèse dans
l'actualité de l'association puisque
vous cherchez des fonds aussi à travers
une plateforme participative c'estul
c'est bien çaoui exactement je viens de
me mettre en place effectivement sur sur
ule ça fait 48 he donc c'est très récent
pour effectivement réaliser et
promouvoir mon nouvel album qu titres
qui va s'appeler femme de Merlin donc
effectivement autour de l'univers de la
magie aussi la magie de Merlin donc
c'est sur hulule j'ai aussi un un site
internet sur lequel vous pouvez
retrouver pas mal d'informations et et
aujourd'hui je je je suis très fière et
en même temps ému de de de lancer
officiellement cette aventure qui n'est
qui n'est que le début d'une belle
aventure puisque j'ai déjà une douzaine
d'autres morceaux en préparation VO vous
serez sur scène lors du gala dont on a
parlé tout à l'heure le 22 novembre ce
sera monfor la Montfort laamis où
actuellement il y a aussi une exposition
qui vient de débuter qui va se
poursuivre jusqu'au 22 jusqu'à la date
exposition sur sur la magie sur des
objets de magie et au-delà de
l'exposition on a reçu toutes les
classes de primaire pour leur montrer
bah justement tous ces objets de magie
et on a pris avec chaque classe un petit
moment pour leur faire une démonstration
de magie alors qu'est-ce qu'est-ce qui
les surprend le plus qu'on vous voit en
pleine démonstration est-ce que les
enfants sont toujours stupéfaits des
tours de magie que vous réalisez ah oui
il y a toujours il y a toujours de la
magie il y a toujours des regards qui on
voit les les yeux qui s'allument et là
on sait que c'est c'est à ce moment-là
que ça c'est ça qui vous plaît dans la
magie c'est le regard justement de il y
a tellement de choses entre autres oui
il y a les rencontres toute la relation
qu'on a avec les avec les gens quand on
fait de la magie par que c'est une
relation qui évolue qu'on qu'on fait
évoluer en fonction des tours qu'on
qu'on va faire qu'on qu'on dirige et
c'est vrai que c'est souvent des belles
rencontres et quand on fait de la magie
il y a beaucoup de barrières qui tombent
il y a plus de réticence et on a une
relation qui est beaucoup plus beaucoup
plus vraie avec les avec les gens et ça
c'est c'est vraiment ça fait partie de
la passion de la magie et mercredi
demain dans le cadre de cette exposition
vous serez aussi présent avec les autres
magiciens du cœur demain mercredi à
partir de 15h on va recevoir les gens
qui on va faire un petit atelier des
petites démos jeudi on va recevoir
encore les les enfants et samedi soir
pardon samedi c'est le gala samedi ce
sera le gala semaine bien remplie pour
pour ces magiciens sachant que la
semaine d'après le 29 samedi 29 c'est le
marché de Noël à Montfort laamorie et
bah on sera aussi présent pour gonfler
des ballons et pour présenter quelques
petits tours de de magie accessible à
tous vous êtes très présent au Monfort
laamorie sur cette période oui oui pour
ce qui veent vous voir c'est làbas qu'
all la la ville de Montfort c'est'est
senti été très impliqué donc c'est vrai
que nous aussi on a envie de de donner
de donner beaucoup pour que pour que la
magie opère la magie justement vous êtes
venu en plateau vous n'allez pas partir
sans faire un petit tour de magie alors
je vais vous montrer souvent ce que je
fais en rentrant dans une chambre à
l'hôpital et ce que je fais quand je
sors de de de la chambre à l'hôpital
donc je vais vous demander de mettre vos
deux mains comme ça j'père que je vais
être aussi dou avec les enfants non
c'est juste donc là je vais vous
expliquer ce qui va se passer cette
boule je la prends je la mettrai dans ma
main et celle-là je la mettrai dans
votre main et à ce moment-là faudra
fermer votre main donc cette cette boule
je la prends vous prenez l'autre vous la
fermez bien vous tournez votre main je
touche votre pouce ou et quand je claque
des doigts vous sentez comme un petit
picotement h et quand ça pique ça passe
c'est très très fort ça c'est c'est très
très fort je vous garantis que nous
n'avions pas répété avant et
effectivement c'est très très fort ça
c'est le tour qu'on fait quand quand on
rentre dans dans une chambre et quand on
quand on part d'une chambre on laisse un
petit souvenir alors on laisse le choix
ça peut être une épée un pistolet ça
peut être un petit nounours et là bah
pour le pour le plateau qui pour
quelques moments je vais vous faire un
petit
chien on rappeler qu'il y aura donc
Galin vMotion d'habitude mtion marche
tout se il y aura ce garslà le 22 on va
rafficher les dates il y a l'exposition
aussi qui se déroule toujours à
montefort lamorie et qui a commencé
aujourd'hui et qui se déroulera jusqu'au
22 jusqu'à la date du gala à Montfort
laamie pour rencontrer ces magiciens qui
interviennent dans les hôpitaux auprès
des enfants malades et qui sont très
forts parce que je me suis fait avoir
comme les enfants vous avez déjà ça fait
plusieurs fois que je vois le tour je
toujours pas compris hein donc pas fait
avoir j'ai réussi à vous étonner oui
vous m'avez étonné surpris mais comme
quoi la magie existe c'est existe
effectivement voilà donc le le tour
d'entrée c'est souvent les petites
boules le tour de sortie on laisse un
petit
souvenir on aura droit au petit
souvenirtit chien hop pour le passage en
plateau sur TVfil de ce petit chien que
vous allez n dédicacer en quelque sorte
ce sera la nouvelle mascotte de ce
journal une mascotte éphémère parce on
verra si elle tient au moins jusqu'à la
fin de la semaine du Gala j'espère voilà
merci beaucoup merci à vous
sur le plateau journal pour parler de
magie et de votre actualité je
vousetrouverai demain mercredi 18h pour
un nouveau journal toujours en direct
point complet sur l'actualité locale
excellente
soirée